BUKOLA AYODELE:
Today, we're talking
about networking revolutions.
Big news for BigQuery and
VMware Engine and visual aids.
I'm Bukola and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Managing and
connecting resources
across on-prem locations and
the Cloud can get complicated.
With the introduction of
Network Connectivity Center,
we deliver global scale
network management
to simplify complex networks for
your Cloud connectivity needs.
With a single
management experience,
network connectivity center
serves as a seamless vantage
point to easily create,
connect, and manage
your on-prem and Cloud
network, leveraging
Google's global infrastructure.
Google has been named a leader
in the Forrester Wave Cloud
data warehouse Q1 2021 report.
For more than a decade, BigQuery
our petabyte scale Cloud data
warehouse, has been
in a class of its own.
We're excited to
share this recognition
and we want to thank our
strong community of customers
and partners for
voicing their opinions.
Are you looking to learn
more about Google Cloud
but prefer something
with visuals?
Head over to Google Cloud
Tech YouTube channel
for a series of
whiteboard videos
that explain Cloud
tools for a tech
audience in about five minutes.
With topics from Cloud Storage
to high performance computing,
there is something for everyone.
If you have VMware
workloads and you
want to modernize
your application
to take advantage
of Cloud Services,
to increase agility, and
reduce total cost of ownership,
then Google Cloud VMware
Engine is the service for you.
Learn more about its benefits,
features, and use cases
on the blog.
And don't forget to check
out the handy cheatsheet too.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.